I sent you some pictures and some lab reports. The pictures seem to show a bit more pink
around the nipple. What are your thoughts on that? So if you have any pinkness or redness
of the skin or if you have good heat sensation on the back of your hand, you could actually
feel for temperature changes or if you have one of those little thermometer checkers that
were popular during COVID and before that where you could check up for their internal temperature,
those are actually really good little units to check temperature on your skin. So
you can check the temperature six inches away from the tumor on the breast and then check
the temperature right at the tumor. And if it's increased in heat, is that a bad thing? Well,
no, that's showing that there's inflammation at the side. Now if you didn't have cancer
and you're not trying to kill cancer cells, then you would say that there's something going on.
Let's say you got a bug bite. If you use that little thermometer surface thermometer on a bug bite,
it would show increase in temperature at the bug bite most likely compared to two inches away
from that bug bite because you have this inflammatory reaction taking place at that bug bite.
Because that's what a bug bite is, is you have the bug that inserted toxins into your skin,
into your body while it took out blood and the bug. And now you have this inflammatory response
to those toxins. And that's why you get this reddish or you get a raised bump or you get itchy,
to get a histamine response, etc. So is that a bad thing with cancer? Well, no, it's not. What's
where you're trying to produce is that. So just because oh my tumors are more red or it's hotter,
that's not really a bad thing. You're trying to get a immune response to kill it. So I wouldn't say
the color is a bad thing. Next part of the question. Last Friday had dark red discharge
for just a little bit but nothing says that. So a dark red discharge was it blood?
That's not that wouldn't be necessarily uncommon. So it's not uncommon to have that change and
have a little bleeding from the dipole or bleeding from the tumor and then it goes away.
So I wouldn't be too concerned about that. Do you have any suggestions with the thyroid
lams? I said I'll have to look at those again. The TSH in March was 1.81, which is fairly low. The tree
free T4 is 0.89, which is low. And the T3 is 3.3, which is with adorable limits. So I, you know,
so remember what you really should be receiving with the thyroid lab. I know this is what you got.
But if you're going to ever request thyroid labs, if anybody is going to ever request thyroid labs,
if you don't get it on our site, then you do want to, you got TSH, you got
free T4 and T3. So that's free T3. You also want to get reverse T3. That tells you if your T4 is
being converted to reverse T3 and issues with the gut. You want to make sure you get TPO antibodies
and you want to make sure you get thyroid globulant antibodies and total T3 and total T4 will be the
other things that would be good to get. That gives you a better picture of what's going on.
If you have elevated TPO antibodies and or thyroid globulant antibodies, then we know
that we have an autoimmune condition going on with the thyroid and now we're dealing with Hashimoto's
and that's a whole other Bala wax. If you don't have elevated T, thyroid globulant or TPO antibodies
that you have low T4 or elevated TSH, then you're concerned with just primary hypothyroidism
and do you want to deal with that. Your thyroid hormones are what they're at right now and let's say
your reverse T3, run, let's say that's within normal limits and you have normal limits of TPO and
thyroid globulant antibodies so those are not elevated. That's pretend since we don't have those
and this was your readings what you gave me. Then you're going to look at the patient's symptoms.
So what are my symptoms? I'm just fatigued all the time. I just don't have any energy. I can't
lose weight. I have losing my hair. I'm losing the outer one third of my eyebrows. I just don't know
what's wrong with me. Then you still want, then you want to supplement if you're not supplemented
with some thyroid stimulators. First of all, before you go to medication, you'd start with some
nutritional support of the thyroid gland, some thyroid glandulars. If I don't remember your case,
I'm sorry, who asked the question. I don't remember if you're already a medication for your thyroid,
but I would not change your medication based upon the test results. I would change the medication
or tweak the nutritional approach based upon your symptoms. Your thyroid gland, you always want to treat
your thyroid based largely based upon your symptoms, not largely based or primarily based upon
the lamps. So if you want more information on this thyroid, go to, I believe it's module 7, 6 or 7
on the autoimmune course. The entire module is dedicated to Hashimoto's and understanding
thyroid lamps. The college has said he is finding that letharzole doesn't work in cancer anymore.
So he's probably talking about your cancer, not cancer in general, but yet he wants me to try it for
six more weeks. He tries this doesn't make sense. So I'm not a doctor, starting to get some tingling
in my back again, in my back again, like back in October, November. Another node started
in under the auxiliary node, the axillary node, I think he said he wants to finish a cycle and do
one more. And then he will look at a different family of chemo pills in shock. I do have an update
into him and we'll see what he says. So let me know what he says.
My mutation is a PIK 3 CA, not as common at breast cancer, not sure if this makes a difference
located to mistletoe therapy again. The tingling in your back, certainly getting another look at that
would might be a good idea. Now your biggest side of like pathological fracture because this
person has met to the bone, biggest concern with pathological fraction symptom wise is going to be
pain. So the tingling in the back doesn't give me such a great concern. There's so many other possibilities
in a differential diagnosis picture to look at with that. I do believe when I looked at your blood
work, would you say to me the other day that your two workers were still elevated?
So yeah, I would have another talk with your oncologist to see what his plans are.